When it comes to films and television shows,
there's a lot riding on an actors' preparedness
for a production.
Even if all of the crew members show up primed
and ready to work, everything can fall apart
if the cast doesn't quite have it together.
These stars got creative and engaged in some
last-minute scrambling to make up for the
fact that they weren't quite prepared for
their roles when they signed on.
Big Momma's coma
In 1999, the world almost lost Martin Lawrence
when the actor collapsed and fell into a coma
outside his L.A. home due to severe heat-related
exhaustion.
Lawrence's condition was so serious that for
several days he required a ventilator just
to breathe.
It all happened largely because he chose to
work out while wearing a big plastic suit
in 100-degree weather to try and get in shape
for Big Momma's House.
"Please, I recommend do not run in a plastic
suit.
Do not do that."
Luckily, he went on to make a full recovery,
but the media criticized Lawrence's decision
to get in shape since he wouldn't have many
opportunities to show off his abs in costume
anyway.
But walking around in an 80-pound bodysuit
still required some fitness preparation, even
if Lawrence took it too far.
Tuned out
Prior to physically appearing in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as Vision, Paul Bettany
never bothered to watch a single film in the
Iron Man franchise, despite providing the
vocals for Jarvis, the hero's trusty AI sidekick.
"Miss Potts is approaching.
I recommend that you…"
"MUTE!"
Even when he was recording his lines as Jarvis,
Bettany didn't even get a full version of
the script and had no context for the dialogue
pieces he read.
"As Jarvis, I would turn up at the end of
the movie and speak into a microphone for
two hours and they'd give me a big whopping,
great bag of cash."
Bettany's indifference to the franchise was
such that he admitted to feeling like a "pirate"
when he took his money, and often had to tell
fans he had no idea who the character was
when he was approached to speak about what
is now one of his most famous roles.
Liquid courage
Undressing in front of one person is hard
enough, so it's gotta be especially awkward
for an actor to strip on camera, with a whole
crew watching from the wings.
For Margot Robbie, her breakout role in The
Wolf of Wall Street called for her to be in
the buff quite a bit, and she knew the shots
would be ruined if her nervousness came through
on-camera.
With little time to prepare herself for one
scene of extreme exposure, decided to do what
a lot of people might do for a confidence
boost, and pounded three shots of tequila
before stripping down and nailing the scene
in one take.
Meanwhile, co-stars Leonardo DiCaprio and
Jonah Hill weren't very familiar with the
effects of most of the drugs they were supposed
to pretend to take on-screen, so both had
to be coached on how to act convincingly high.
"Steve."
"STEEEVE."
In fact, DiCaprio was so unsure about how
to act, he'd later admit that he spent hours
watching this YouTube video of a guy drunkenly
rolling around on the floor to better shape
his performance.
Learning the lingo
When Jackie Chan first arrived in the U.S.
in the 1980s, he was reportedly unable to
speak even basic English and quickly set about
teaching himself how to communicate by absorbing
Western media.
He came to America alone to "immerse himself
in the English-speaking world" and learn the
language that way.
Although Chan did pick up on English pretty
well over the years, he still had trouble
reading scripts as late as the Rush Hour series
and had to learn the lines for many of his
Western films phonetically.
"Do you understand the words that are coming
out of my mouth?"
Sometimes, crews would take advantage of this
and make Chan say swear words or things he
didn't mean, just for laughs.
"I'm into feet.
I like the one with the horses.
What's that mean?
What he teach me?"
Doing dialect
Most of the actors in Games of Thrones have
accents based on where in the fictional world
of Westeros they hail from, relative to the
geography of the U.K.
For example, characters hailing from the North
have thick Northern accents, whereas those
from the south speak with accents commonly
found in the more southerly parts of the U.K.
Production was reportedly insistent that the
actors playing the sons of Ned Stark should
adopt Sean Bean's native Yorkshire accent,
but Kit Harington had no idea that this would
be expected of him and auditioned for the
role of Jon Snow in his native southern accent.
Although he was told he was a good match for
the character, he still needed to speak more
like his on-screen dad before the cameras
started rolling.
So Harington—along with the rest of the
actors expected to portray Ned Stark's sons—had
to rush to ready their new dialects to match
their daddy's off-screen affectation.
Getting ripped
Upon being cast to play infamous British criminal
Charles Bronson, a man so dangerously violent
and superhumanly built he once punched clean
through bulletproof glass in a fit of anger,
Tom Hardy met with the man himself to see
if he'd sign off his portrayal.
Bronson was unimpressed with Hardy's physique,
however, and initially said no.
Hoping to change Bronson's mind, Hardy started
bulking up after their first meeting, consuming
nothing but pizza, ice cream, chicken and
rice while exercising as hard as he could.
Two weeks later, he'd bulked up enough for
Bronson to realize he was committed to physically
portraying him.
The fact that Hardy also brought Bronson a
muffin and some milkshakes also likely didn't
hurt.
Along with giving the actor his blessing,
Bronson also shaved off his mustache and mailed
it to Hardy, hoping the makeup department
could figure out a way to glue it to his face.
Failing that, Bronson hoped Hardy could carry
the clippings around in his pocket as a good
luck charm.
It's unclear which option Hardy chose.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!